now south africa's president says a week
of violence and looting was planned and
coordinated sil ramaposa says forces
have identified 12 ringleaders and
he's deployed 25 000 soldiers onto the
streets to help defuse the situation
at least 212 people have been killed as
of friday
the violence was sparked by the jailing
former president jacob zuma but then
widened into anger over poverty and
inequality
haru mutasa is in johannesburg with more
well the general mood right now in south
africa is
that of relief for about a week now many
businesses have been closed
some of them weren't even affected by
the violence so for about a week people
couldn't access banks
they could access certain services
rubbish wasn't being collected now
they've been told the main highway
between
durban and johannesburg is now open
which means goods can now move
it also means goods can leave south
africa by road and go to other countries
in the region such as zimbabwe
zambia and botswana for example the two
things that people took away
from president trump opposes speech was
economic sabotage
and as well as that these protests were
planned
he seemed to suggest that there are
individuals in
the country who are trying to topple
this government who are trying to
destabilize this economy there's
speculation of course as to who these
individuals are they haven't actually
been named but
most africans know that within the
ruling african national congress party
they've been
divisions and factions for many many
years and right now
those divisions seem to center around
two men the former president jacob zuma
and sarah ramaphosa as well so it seems
to be a fight or wrangle within that
party
over who controls the party maybe even
who controls the running of the country
in terms of the day-to-day
events so people are watching that very
very closely of course they also know
because of these factions
because these divisions within the anc
these things will likely play out at
least
until the country heads to local
government elections
later this year